welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons here to break down
episode 7 of She-Hulk for you we spent
some time back with Emil Blonsky getting
a gander at The Retreat we've heard so
much about we're introduced to the best
damn group of friends a girl can have
and this episode really sums up my late
20s so let's get into it God this
episode really really just came for me
and I did not like it anyways we opened
up to a shot of Jen's bathroom which is
gorgeous this is a God's eye view in
filmmaking it captures the overhead
angle directly above the subject hence
the name God's view most commonly used
in Wes Anderson movies I genuinely love
this though it makes you feel unfamiliar
with the character I think it opens the
space for you to interpret so much more
about them their movements the
environment and how they maneuver and
set space Etc these are the kind of
great shots for visual storytelling that
I love and kind of like in Miss Marvel
we're getting the floating bubble text
we see it's a text message from Josh the
man she met at Lulu's wedding last
episode and I hate him now I think we
already have a right to be suspicious of
him with this weird message he sends to
Jen and Jen's like how do you know what
neighborhood I live in he's a sketchy
dude also firm Jen lives near West
Hollywood in the Fairfax area with that
90036 zip code so no wonder she likes to
party and have money Jen listening to
Spotify and this song really opens up
the episode it looks like she's
listening to fubt from heim's recent
album women in music part three but what
we really hear is now I'm in it the
bonus track to that album the opening
line is literally about waking up
looking in the mirror and not
recognizing yourself Heim said it's
almost like every accidental crisis
you're like this person is me but I
don't recognize myself so I think this
is a perfect map into Jen right now this
shot of Jen's bathroom and bedroom and
the single Dolly shot around her house
is oh Chef kiss the shot I'd call sort
of a tracking shot most tracking shots
the camera is following the character
but this feels more like Jen is
following the camera either way it
immediately reminded me of the breakup
scene in I Tonya With Goodbye Stranger
how the camera pans through the entire
apartment different shots of Sebastian
stand just spiraling this shot is
completely thematically pleasing the two
shots definitely are perfect for
expressing the duration of time that's
been spent contemplating and just
waiting I would love to just talk to
this DP and director about these shots
because this is giving 16 Candles the
yeah you is it our Jake absolutely not I
hate Josh and I hope he dies presumably
their first date is a taco truck which
you can see the QR code this week's
comic leads you to Tales to astonish
came out in 1959 issue number 48 Ant-Man
and the WASP battle the porcupine for
free
oh I hit that note
okay and when she goes home they
awkwardly shake hands goodbye this guy
has Jen distracted texting under the
table during a meeting they go to a flea
market and doesn't that dog just look
like Jonathan and then there's no sexy
time no sexy time here they go to a
drive-in they have a great time and then
there is sexy time the next day it's
Friday Josh is just gone which would
piss me off but Jen is just happy for
now Jen is wearing a nice Plum suit
that's similar to her iconic purple suit
in the comics and Josh still hasn't
responded because he sucks we're at GLK
H Nikki common said Jen's been nominated
as sclas female lawyer of the year which
is the gala that she attends in the
sparkly dress that we see from the
trailer it actually stands for Southern
California law Awards we also think at
the same time as that trailer we get
these guys with the same looking machine
that sent those sort of high pitch
frequencies that worked on hook up until
it didn't so this could be another setup
or you know fingers crossed this is
where she's just planning to meet
Daredevil please I just don't want
another setup my heart can't take it
anymore Nikki says this oh are you going
down a rabbit hole on that
Intelligentsia site if you remember the
last episode this is the website that
spews trash on women specifically
She-Hulk and even trades knowledge on
how and if you can harm her Mallory
didn't want her mentioning the site to
Jen and Nikki as a best friend
immediately calls her and leaves her a
voicemail telling her exactly what it is
but Jen's clearly not phased because
she's got bigger things on her mind if
you get one I'm saying why am I
complimenting him I hate him I love that
it's now just a joke for Jen to say
she'd Hulk smash the trolls on the
internet like Hulk didn't do absolute
hardcore damage also Nikki's notepad
just says get it done with a couple of
notes and I love her even more Jen's
getting a little pissed and a little
scary in this shot that gives me the
same heebie-jeebies from the beginning
of A Clockwork Orange she's gone mad God
this is completely me her phone
transitions into her TV where she's
watching the great month at Caper Jen's
about to break out of this prison just
like Miss Piggy the next morning Jen is
woken up by a Mills parole officer Chuck
Donald and played by John prusio I hope
I pronounced that right who works with
the California Department of Corrections
you can also see on her nightstand the
books for behold the dreamers and In
Cold Blood which I think is Truman
Capote I just love her this entire
conversation with Chuck is only looking
for sweets and the balloons behind him
say happy retirement so someone
definitely has cake there she's on her
way to see a mill through Malibu Canyon
and on the way she can't stop checking
her phone to see if Josh has responded
but she does take a break and listen to
um by Hanson and I feel it we reached
the retreat and from the outside it
looks massive it's called Summer
Twilights and Chuck refers to her as the
jolly green which I assume the Jolly
Green Giant another nickname for the
books and I love that she corrects and
confirms it is hulking out instead of
turning into a jolly green suit or
whatever I just like her correcting
people so Chuck is fixing a Mill's
inhibitor that he messed up when
touching the electric fence his favorite
chicken was stuck in Princess silk
feathers so yeah that story sounds
completely made up but maybe maybe he is
that cartoony the only reason I'm led to
believe that Emil is lying is because we
see him in the mid-season trailer as
Abomination so perhaps he's been
changing back and forth but also let's
know that in that mid-season trailer
only men are high-fiving him and we've
been watching the show so we can't trust
most of them been on it so it's a little
bit off but I just want us to keep it
noted not long after Chuck leaves were
introduced to man bull played by Nathan
Hurd and Ella Gila played by Joseph
Castillo in the comics man bull aka
William torens was injected with a
special Serum by the professor who was
instructed by Mr Klein this serum was
based on bull enzymes which mute him
until a half man half bull hence the
name man bull as for eligila AKA
Alejandro Montoya he's a mutant a mutant
a mutant a mutant you say and he can
shoot bioelectric energy blast but he
would use sword to control that energy
blast he's a skilled fencer an acrobat
though some see him as an underwhelming
character he's actually really really
cool and basically played Robin Hood to
all the people in New York and he's a
swashbuckler dang it if you don't know
what that is it's a person who engages
in daring and romantic adventures with
bravado or flamboyance make him my man
that's all I'm saying yeah so summer
Twilight is huge they even have a sweat
gear and this one could be a ceremonial
sweat lodge a year also looks like this
usually made up of all natural materials
similar to tense but much much bigger a
lot of people even live in them now
they're super cool when Jenna's not
enough and is looking for service the
song playing is peppers and onions by
Tierra whack basically about figuring
things out for yourself and just being a
human which gen will do shortly Jen
wanders into the real Retreat Emil is
talking about we immediately see the
goddess Sarah sweetie we see the Seas
your true power Obama stay a play on
Namaste I also like Obama nasty I wish
they would have kept that achieve
everything some Hindu worship practices
a Jar full of bills that says chicken
jar and a better shot later we see
blonsky's Proverbs today is today day
and make your goal a reality we also see
Lord Ganesh behind a mill you see coffee
photos of himself it looks like a
self-help money bag Retreat he's just
like making money off these folks maybe
I don't want to believe he's bad I
really want to believe Emil's good now
but I don't know you can't trust anyone
uh it's like they're all squirrels we've
met man Bull and Aguila but we haven't
met porcupine played by Jordan Aaron
Ford there are two people that wore the
porcupine suit the OG porcupine Alex
Gentry and currently Roger gawking who
bought the suit off of hobgoblin the OG
porcupine was a weapon designer and made
their intense suit covered in quills
that was able to shoot gases chemicals
and the quill sometimes he made this
suit for the government but when he knew
they wouldn't pay him as much as the
suit was worth He just engaged in his
own money-filled crimes and I kind of
like that sarson played by Terence Khloe
AKA musafar Lambert in some parts
there's two saracens and Marvel Comics
musafar is a mercenary and assassin that
we first set up in the Punisher series
while saracen is one of the first
vampires on Earth we first met him in
Blade vampire Hunter issue number one so
that could be the reason why a Mill's
confusion on whether he's a vampire or
not Jen breaks the fourth wall for the
first time this episode to remind us
that that dummy that tried jumping her
in The Wrecking Crew from episode 3 is
here also they did previously on him but
in episode 4 and slightly in episode six
and I don't care I still think he's a
villain on the down low he was one of
the people that ushered her to delete
Josh's number first maybe to lose
evidence also I believe in people
changing but Jen this guy was clearly
working for something bigger talk to him
investigate him let's take a break
because you know why be sure to head
over to new rockstarsmerch.com to grab
our latest Obsession shirt Lady Justice
inspired by the She-Hulk attorney at law
Series this shirt is a limited edition
and when you purchase it you unlock the
ability to get a custom shout out from
me and to your boss that will appear
right here on inside Marvel not here but
you know on inside Marvel it came out
yesterday support the channel check out
all of our awesome merch options over at
New rockstarsmerch.com and you just have
a ball you guys I have a ball g-hole is
more than a pretty face in fact right
now I want to talk about her hair it's
gorgeous if you want Gorgeous Hair you
should check out geology and you know I
love geology I put it all over my body
and I know you're all thinking geology
isn't that about 13 times award-winning
skin care company with over 5 000 5 Star
reviews yes they are
they are how they do hair too and I'm
super excited about it geology has a new
custom control hair care line with brand
new co-wash co-wash is the anti-shampoo
shampoo strips your hair of the
essential oils of the scalp produces and
can leave your hair and scalp too dry
like the Sahara typical shampoos use
harsh chemicals to clean your hair
co-wash uses friction and scrubbing
motion to remove dirt and grime from
your scalp and I know you guys got Dirty
Heads keeping your hair clean and
healthy without damaging it in the
process and let me tell you I know a lot
about damaged hair good hair comes with
having healthy scalp co-wash focuses on
cleansing and nourishing the scalp
remove and build up and cleansing the
hair without big lather harsh
ingredients or stripping your hair of
its natural oils nobody wants to strip
anything of anything co-wash puts you
100 in control of your clean based on
how much product you use how long you
use it and how often you apply it think
of co-wash as a skin care for your scalp
and your hair two in one anymore because
ultimately Hair Care is skin care
more you know geology hair products are
great for all hair types and are color
safe and you can either get a cooling
co-wash with tea tree and aloe or a
smoothing cold wash with avocado and
coconut I'm a tea tree and aloe kind of
person why because you can never be too
cool
to celebrate the launch of their new
product they are hooking you up with the
unbelievable special offer click the
link below to get 70 off your skin care
trial 70 off 70s a lot that's how old
Eric Voss is use the second link to take
an additional 15 off the new co-wash
that's how old I am which is already 15
off your pre-order you are not going to
want to miss this offer you guys it's
great in a very bad manner Emil says
look at you you are glued to that thing
this isn't the first dad Behavior Jen's
got from clients come on I feel like
you're dead when they start giving her
group advice it's way too close to home
I've texted someone I can't stop smiling
is that bad is that horrible I thought
that was a nice thing to say I've said
that before and this episode just hits
me in different feels I love everybody
here everybody in this group except for
the record I love everyone but saracen
is definitely by far my favorite with
this call out about the blood okay did
we or did we not say he's trying to get
her DNA Josh was completely just trying
to get her blood saracen may be a weirdo
to some but he's on the money he wanted
her blood and I just love the call out
how can you hate the speech that Jen
gives how can people not like Jen this
scene when Jen explains having to be Jen
or She-Hulk when she is Gen through and
through and when she said Jen is great I
was clapping I was so happy I was
watching this by myself in my house and
I was so ecstatic because look we've all
been ghost sillies once and if you
haven't great but I have and it sucks it
hurts especially when you give this
person everything of you so this speech
of never finding someone to like both
sides of herself is great and ioper and
I'm sure what a lot of us needed and
like a gila said Josh has made an enemy
of this entire group Josh has made an
enemy of this entire group also I just
love this group of men except for maybe
record but the rest are great not only
did Rutgers straight up say it smells
like a fart when porcupine took off his
mask but my baby boy said what am I ashy
baby be for real with all that moisture
locked in that suit oh I feel like
they're improvising everything and I
love it peep Jen's contacts in her phone
there's a lot of people and I'm gonna go
through the meech because I'm a weirdo
God Jacobs is an editor for she-hole
Luke Jacobson is the designer that made
her outfits Wendy Jacobson is a co-ep on
She-Hulk Jamie this could be Jamie
Hallett the VFX supervisor Giselle
Johnson the director of post-production
streaming at Marvel Studios Jesse
Johnson the vfxpa Jessica is just as
Jessica this could be me but I I it
probably isn't it's probably Jessica gal
some people have speculated it could be
Jessica Jones since it's where her last
name would be but it's also an
alphabetical order if her last name was
missing so it's still kind of up in the
air Justison Justison Pratt and Anderson
it's probably Shannon Justin the VFX
supervisor Sarah Pratt the VFX
coordinator Anderson could be a few
folks the set dresser Michelle Anderson
comic writer Bill Anderson Craig
Anderson the list goes on Mike chemins
though is a VFX editor on She-Hulk cat
is probably cat Coro Kelly could be for
Kelly Alyssa Cunningham that works in
the editorial department for She-Hulk
Adam kemerlin is another editor at
Marvel Doran Kipper who was the data
Wrangler first She-Hulk kanuk I hope I
pronounced that right who I assume is
Robert Knuck a VFX supervisor at Marvel
if you're in VFX this is the perfect
time to just slide in your own little
Easter eggs we get a shout out to slot
towing a nod to dance slots comic run of
Sensational She-Hulk I tried calling the
number attached to slots towing company
and it leads nowhere so don't even
bother we pulled out to Dua lipa's IDGAF
because I'm not gonna say that f word a
song about a breakup where she owes her
ex-boyfriend nothing she doesn't care
like Jen as she rides away with Dan the
tow truck driver it looks like his name
is Dan on the badge might be Danny I'll
just give it to Dan for dance lot three
days earlier and oh we knew it we knew
Josh was a low down dirty sneaky Gremlin
looking no faith having ass hat working
for that damn Hulk King he's copying all
the Jen's information from her phone and
snapped a photo of her because he's a
monster and a creep though this could be
proof that he did the job I could see
this monster posting this photo on the
Intelligentsia website later I hope not
but they just want to destroy her and
her career then he sends three emojis
like Jen did earlier about the fries
confirming he's got the real blood in
our recent episode of inside Marvel boss
speculates Josh got her blood with a
syringe while she was asleep because we
see two moles on her back that could be
markings from the syringe boss
Tatiana maslani's shoulders and he said
she has no moles so it could be valid
and true I think it's wild but yeah he
could be right new courtroom
illustrations we have are Aguila in
college his Letterman's jacket that says
matadorian JV we have a hallway of party
goers and a man clearly impersonating a
bull but those ears are giving Loki jet
in the game but you know not that kind
of gang meditating and what I assume is
the yurt porcupine getting his stinky
suit dry clean you guys that's
everything I spotted in episode 7 of
She-Hulk follow me on Instagram and
Twitter Lulu underscore Clemons full of
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching and I'm hurting
for a urting baby wow wow
[Music]